- Hi everyone, my name is Luka Negoita
and I'm an ecologist and a data scientist
and I've always wanted
to make a course on R
that I wish I had as a grad
student going into ecology.
(upbeat music)
I think that one of the hardest parts
with starting a grad program in ecology
is really getting a good grasp of R.
And it's frustrating because R is a tool
that should help us do good science,
not stand in the way of it.
The point of this course
is really to eliminate
that frustration and anxiety
so that you can really start plotting
and exploring your data on your own
and feel really comfortable doing it.
The project-based lessons and exercises
in this course are designed
to take you by the hand
through the most essential tools in R,
beginning with things as simple
as how to install R and RStudio,
how to upload your own data
but then getting into the
more advanced data wrangling,
data management, creating
publication-quality figures,
learning how to organize your projects
and doing all of this while
feeling really confident.
Now, this course doesn't
cover any data analysis
or modeling but that's really the point.
There's a lot of R courses out there
that try to cover everything
and I think that can be really
overwhelming for beginners
to really grasp the foundation.
This course is designed
for students in ecology,
whether you're a grad student
or an undergraduate student.
But really this course
is applicable to anyone
that wants a solid foundation
in the basics of R.
If you're interested in this course,
check out the link
below in the description
so you can register.
Registration for this initial launch
I only open for one week.
So make sure you register
as soon as you can.
Thank you so much for watching
and please share this with anyone
that you could benefit from this course.
(lively music)